to turkey now where president recep
tayyip erdogan has pressed ahead with a
widely criticized plan to cut its key
interest rate for a fourth time in a row
this as turkey's currency the lira hits
a new all-time low against the u.s
dollar erdogan hopes his move will bring
down inflation which has seen the cost
of basic goods soar and many people
struggle to make ends meet dw
correspondent yulia han has this report
from istanbul
the only food hiriacelli can prepare for
her family is eggs and tomatoes
she can't afford more
and sometimes she can't even afford that
it make energy we have to save on bread
now because it has become so expensive
sometimes i go to bed hungry
i don't eat so at least my children
won't starve
the chilex have an income of roughly 3
000 turkish liras a month from hyria's
husband's job
that's the equivalent of around 180
euros
it has always been very little money for
a family of four
but now it's no longer enough to make
ends meet
food prices and the cost of electricity
heating and water have sought so much
that hari is struggling to pay her bills
hey
i have debts everywhere by the end of
the months all our money is gone and we
have nothing left
kyrie is not alone
double-digit inflation and a crushing
currency are turning the incomes and
savings of millions of turks to dust
the lira has lost 50 percent of its
value against the dollar since the
beginning of the year
more than almost any other currency
[Applause]
discontent is growing in recent weeks
demonstrators took to the streets in
istanbul and ankara
they called for the government to resign
many lay the blame for turkey's currency
crisis on president dredja tayyip
erdogan every time he pressures the
country's central bank and calls for
interest rate cuts the lira plummets
even further economists warn inflation
is spiraling out of control and turkish
consumers are the ones who literally
have to pay the price
i just paid 200 liras but only got a few
kilograms of fruit a pack of eggs and
one kilo of cheese that's shameful
those in power say that they have a plan
for our country but i don't see it
we ordinary people are suffering
i just want to get out of turkey i don't
see a future here the economy is very
bad inflation is way too high
but president erdogan holds the
unconventional view that lower interest
rates fight inflation
and despite the lira crashing shows no
sign of changing his position
what we're doing might be politically
very risky
but it's the right plan for our country
and our nation
haircelic doesn't know much about
interest rates and inflation
she says she has no way of knowing which
plan is the right one
but one thing she knows for sure
with money that is worth less and less
she can't provide for her family
so let's get more on this story from jan
he is an analyst at the edom think tank
in istanbul turkey a warm welcome jan
we're seeing a surge in inflation around
the world right now but almost nowhere
as dramatically as in turkey why is that
well a couple of reasons because you
know turkey is diverging significantly
in its uh policy choice
uh in its monetary policy choice uh when
it comes to dealing with these you know
macro economic issues i think that's
number one reason why
uh the inflation uh surge in in turkey
is quite different and significant than
uh elsewhere in the world
now those different policy choices
critics say that president erdogan is
putting pressure on his country's
central bank and replacing his finance
ministers is only making things worse
can you explain his strategy
well first of all uh president erdogan
and his current economic management team
has a fundamental fundamentally believed
that
uh you know high interest rates uh cause
uh inflation uh rather than you know uh
conventional uh what conventional wisdom
tells us which is the vice versa now
this new economic model that has been
introduced
uh aims to uh you know uh aims at lower
interest rates that depreciated lyra in
order to boost
exports uh you know boost the
construction sector and the tourism
sector uh in an attempt to close the
current account deficit whereby uh you
know the the cash problem of turkey will
be resolved and that
surplus will go into investment
and which will you know uh value the
lyra
and bring down inflation which you know
many economists including myself
find rather a difficult uh path towards
lowering inflation indeed we saw in our
report just now how prices for food and
energy have soared to the point where
even middle-income families are
struggling after years of what has been
progress in turkey in reducing poverty
is it fair to say that erdogan's
policies are reversing those hard-earned
gains
oh absolutely i mean
right now look turkey has been
experiencing macroeconomic issues since
august 2018 and we are almost entering
our third year whereby turkey has
double-digit unemployment and double
digit inflation so the household middle
income and lower income and also you
know the entire households i would say
are experiencing a continued loss of
revenue as well as continued uh
loss of purchasing power right now the
volatility is at a point where
producers are finding it for of goods
and services are finding it very
difficult to price
their products i mean at the retail
level uh you know prices are set almost
on a daily basis and longer term trade
has almost come to a stop because you
know it's very difficult for
uh traders to to price their
their inputs
and their and their final products
john celchuki we're going to leave it
there but thank you so much for joining
us on dw news my pleasure
you